on en parle avec vous nicolas roux vous
êtes porte-parole de l'association des
amis de la terre bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
d'abord qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur cet accord de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et le vietnam à
ce que c'est un accord qui est
stratégique dont contexte que l'on
connaît actuellement notamment un
contexte de guerre commerciale avec la
chine
bonjour il oui il est stratégique dans
la mesure où l union européenne va se
voir un peu cette domination
commerciales à travers le monde
mais je dois dire que nous on est assez
consterné en fait qu'en 2020 on se
demande comment on peut encore signer ce
genre d'accords commerciaux qui ne
prennent pas en compte les défis
auxquels font face les populations aussi
bien en union européenne
conviés et même au delà d'ailleurs c'est
à dire des défis on prend pas en compte
la baisse des inégalités la la promotion
du développement durable la lutte contre
le changement climatique
tout cela est absent de cet accord or la
commission européenne veut mettre en
avant un green deal veut faire de
l'action écologique une priorité mais
mais cela est complètement absent de cet
accord qu'est ce que vous reprochez
au vietnam vietnam proportion rien
vraiment au vietnam en tant pays aux
vietnamiens mais il faut voir constate
que le vietnam quand même en termes de
droits de l'homme la situation est quand
même très préoccupante
le parlement européen elle avait
d'ailleurs noté en 2017 il avait noté
qu'il y avait une détérioration des
droits civils et politiques au vietnam
notamment respect des libertés publiques
comme la liberté d'expression ou où la
liberté de la presse
répression contre les activistes contre
les journalistes qui expriment des
critiques face au régime est encore plus
important le vietnam n'a toujours pas
ratifié deux des huit conventions
fondamentales de l'organisation
internationale du travail et des
conventions sur la liberté syndicale et
l'abolition du travail forcé donc on se
demande comment l'union européenne peut
au jour d'aujourd'hui en 2020 si des
accords commerciaux avec des dictatures
est ce que est ce qu'on peut imaginer
justement que cet accord de traité de
libre-échange avec le vietnam et bien il
inclut des directives des strictes
justement pour pouvoir réguler un peu
les secteurs qui sont concernés c'est
quelque chose qu'on nous vend depuis
depuis 25 ans depuis l'alena
c'est-à-dire l'accord de libre échange
nord américain
il n'y a rien qui garantit dans l'accord
union européenne vietnam que le vietnam
va effectivement signer ces conventions
et on l'a vu dans nombre d'accords comme
la lena dont j'ai parlé ou soi-disant
l'alena et la promotion d'environnement
et hydro sociaux s'est passé exactement
le contraire pendant les 25 ans ou
l'aller n'a été mise en oeuvre
donc on se demande vraiment comment cet
accord union européenne vietnam va
changer la donne
70 ong 1
vous faites partie justement qui ont
appelé les eurodéputés à ne pas ratifier
cet accord maintenant parlement à la
décidé autrement puisqu'il l'a ratifié
hier
quels sont les recours possibles votre
niveau
un autre niveau le seul recours qui est
possible malheureusement parce que là il
faut voir quelle commission européenne a
décidé de séparer les accords en 2 donc
et l'accord commercial est purement une
compétence européenne donc à notre
niveau actuel et c'est un peu compliqué
après il ya un autre volet qui le volet
de l'investissement qui contient des
clauses très dangereuse sur l'arbitrage
donc il permet à des compagnies
d'attaqué des états si noah ou un
règlement nouveaux vont à l'encontre de
leurs profits escomptés
donc c'est quelque chose que nous
pouvons que nous pouvons faire tomber au
niveau national car tous les parlements
européens nationaux et régionaux devront
se prononcer sur cette partie
investissement
merci beaucoup à nicolas roux je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
de l'association les amis de la terre
merci à vous merci